we spent a lot of time on a chain me you
Eddie Bravo on Rogen if you want we do
yeah and any sense a lot of conspiracy
things and then what i do is i bunk them
and then and then Eddie comes back with
some like a video we shot Eddie side now
yeah you got I keep going hashtag Tommy
yeah you call me government she'll go
Eddie you egg them on and then Eddie
comes back with something else and then
Rogan will go this is a very
constructive thread you guys are gonna
get to the bottom of this I'm sure this
IDEO is this is very constructive and a
good way to spend your time this isn't a
waste time at all you how about corona
starting to pop off a little bit is it
is it is it a little bit was a statewide
uh emergency in Washington when I was
there like well I'm out of here but its
height and I still went to the gun dumb
wall what no it's also hype I took six
planes over the week six planes I'm sure
some people okay but they said it is
gonna be a problem
really I'm not a compromised immune
system and then I found out that the men
the people are collapsing in China were
men over sixty and they were heavy
smokers with diminished lung capacity
yeah you know people that's like six
people died right now in Washington they
just went up to six but do we know how
how old they were I don't know the ages
there were they were Asian they were
Chinese from China I think but they're
both they're from China but they're
Americans and they were there were 70 or
80 years old and they know what the one
dinner Irvine they it was like an old
person's home yeah and like an old lady
got it
but then one of her like family motors
travel from China yeah I mean so you
know she was let some dog got it
kill them what and then they say that
ass don't do [ __ ] I'm ask them do that's
just all the fire they don't do it yeah
oh there you go two in their 80s one in
their 70s okay so that's father time
like yeah easier this of the fluid yeah
so you know pick your pick your poison
like either we're gonna get you
Hades yeah yeah bigger bigger issues
these things these things happen when
you when you flout when you flout
agricultural laws when you when you have
wild animal markets and those viruses
mutate like in China or China was crying
creative chemical weapon of warfare
well the weapon that was like a German
walk out like oh well the German war
friend I have is really really rough
[ __ ] but that that's how they think that
they think that's gonna be the biggest
problem in a few years though the
disease warfare where they release a
virus yeah and then we can't figure it
out hey when you think about it even at
the mouth that right this is a dark
podcast what though
just saying even if it took out you know
ten million people still be awful
yeah world keep it more less traffic
because that we're trying to save less
traffic well in Ellie engine more
beachfront property yeah you know yeah
that's why I used to do a joke about
that which is to just an indictment on
human beings if a billion people died to
be horrible but if it was no one you
knew and they were way over there you
wouldn't miss work over it oh that's
going on minutes every day and okay john
c reilly this has been going viral right
now cuz john c rallies son is actually a
model check this out that's his son
people just found out that he looks this
good and they're wondering how that's
possible yeah good looking he has the
same eyes as his dad and lips that's his
wife oh they're so cute
that's why yeah let me see his wife i'm
just watch white but she this looks like
her face looks more like the sun yes
middle easterners she almost looks like
she could be Indian or Middle English
son looks like her for sure but them
together made that guy he's a musician
to play 30 games ik we won't be able to
play the music won't give me a Brian
here yeah he's a model da he was better
looking that other one yeah I mean this
is Instagram there he looks very
generate me like the guy from Queens no
he looks very much like it's like
Freddie Mercury yeah more like what
who's who's I don't think it looks like
Freddie working now he looks more like
the guy from Azerbaijan who was they as
a good-looking dude who's the guy come
on who's the guy who played them
give me the movie for god sake it was it
was a [ __ ] hilarious movie and boy
yeah it looks like yeah he's a
good-looking dude for sure
Harry is poor at some of the pictures
guys are fine John he's a good-looking
dude it's just crazy as dad you know
that's cool
good for him it is crazy it is pretty
crazy okay you seen these yet they're so
terrible oh my god kind of off the kanji
trade right now since you got so
religious and look as leather pants whoa
those Easy's are terrible they look like
growth sized feet uh-huh uh-huh
yeah just not into it all right all
right I'm getting ready for my Crocs
whoo what I'm gonna wear Crocs on this
one say cuz it's a free country suit I'm
gonna stand up to last for two months
later I'm wearing yeah
all right now I've been off the adidas
why he trained why yeah he's just a
little too crazy I don't like the way
they're going I don't know where those
well he's sober now was that he's not it
was he emerges as religious as he's
never he hasn't always been religious he
has his prayer I think is religion have
you been rude invited to that to the the
Sunday service yeah a service no
somebody else we know has right I've run
by it you do yeah or you see it that's
right my necklace oh let's hear it all
the time
really yeah not for me I'm all set again
it was lost there you know are you doing
I'm all wearing the easies and they were
in his like clothes really that's a
bunch of [ __ ] faces man he's got his
girl he's got the biggest ego on the
planet holy [ __ ] they all do and they're
they think they're trying to say it's
for God its I can't be around it I can
what are you around me buddy is wearing
all this right now you're out here right
they rope off this area this private
land you came in with a helicopter what
are you doing it's all fake
I know I just met this it is agree I
agree with this music is less CD was
[ __ ] trash was it I'll trash some
people liked it
yeah yes it did exhausting guy here
now I'm gonna say this another gay man
but I've seen my share fair dicks so I'm
Chris his dick today said send him a pic
of it and it is it's long and a little
thin you know this nonsense I got girth
long thin long and thin and and and you
can verify one more which is not that
bad
it's one more no just like that is bad
right that's it's just one there's guys
are there have in double digits I have
one we're a little wart now we gotta get
that taken care of I asked him how much
he bandaged he lied to me I didn't lie
deal and I got [ __ ] also I got good
news too just just hot off the president
of the doctor are you cool if I choke on
your your yeah absolutely oh absolutely
um just so everybody just win a bar
stool sport shirt by the way in the
courts not a bad dick dude no no good I
was impressed for my this kid's got a
[ __ ] piece on I got a hug I mean I'm
very impressed with that it's long it's
got some girl long yeah a little bit
yours is girth here for sure I'm gonna
we're in the middle of you two yeah no
my big looks at your dicks head babies
the Stefan has got a piece on dude I
told you I'm solid eight inches 8 inches
9 butt warts 9 with warts yeah that's a
that's a Brooklyn right back no dude
come on
yeah so brooklyn oh ye like I got this
just just had the tea well the last I
read the comic story him insanity and I
get the picture from Troy I said I hit
your hey we models yeah home to friendly
models 9:00 a.m. you do so it I was
driving oh my god yeah dude
well good for you man and then I just
got the email today Chlamydia
trachomatis negative gonorrhea and
gonorrhea RNA negative vaginitis
positive no it's the herpes 1 negative
herpes 2 positive
HIV mm-hmm we don't know negative
negative negative so far never they do
that guess little is more so people just
don't people just don't know
I literally because you know Tom Segura
is doing Stan podcasts in Spanish now
yes so my kids mom's family you know
Puerto Rican they speak Spanish but
listening to podcasts one of the [ __ ]
one of her Tio's I don't know which one
it was Ramon whatever one of their
uncles one of them one of the guys that
knows as we call yeah yeah one one of
the one of the JT toast comes up to me
and he says we're at a family party and
he's got a live rooster no it comes up
to me and he goes he goes he goes you
noticed Tom Segura and I said and I said
yeah I said hey you know I know I'm you
know I don't know well I said but I know
I'm a fan of his work whatever I we've
communicate a little bit met him once
and he goes out he goes yeah I blissing
to his podcast it's pretty good it's in
Spanish I go yeah he goes um he goes he
goes what is he like an up-and-comer
open-mike her and then I sent him a
article that the new seven million
dollar house he just bought I said yeah
there's your open mic er yeah yeah
[ __ ] stupid repellent Tim what do you
want dum-dum how dummy an open mic huh
open mic what what is he Spanish is that
was his first language Spanish yeah well
he does his mama is yes I'm like yeah
not but I think he's Spanish but not
Mexican it's Spanish I don't know if
it's Cuban I figure what it is Porto
Ricans I'm not a teaspoon I figure what
it is but he's Spanish but yeah he does
a podcast on Spanish and now he's doing
a special in all Spanish smart he signed
two with Netflix for one rather special
one Spanish special amazing
yeah he's oh he's only been probably of
nine years he'll Peruvian who's got good
culture they make good uh potato so I
wanna do Heil Wasco yes Sugar's Abby's
me me real moneys yeah man in stir so I
know I don't know by well can you they
asked me they were like yo dude like
water Chinese food they're like get
butt-naked they said and put on this
Miami Dolphins helmet and your mother's
high heels and I was like that ok that's
weird I know that's true I swear to God
so we open the door so they said and
then answer the Chinese food goddess yo
to be funny answer the Chinese answer
the for the
like that with the Miami Dolphins helmet
on bought naked your mother's high heels
I was like absolutely dude I want you
guys to like me so and so it's all so
true comic in the making how this true
crack in the make so literally we all go
down with like dial F I'm dissing you
great open the door see obviously the
Chinese guys [ __ ] surprised then they
push me out the door and lock the door
so now I'm butt-naked on the actual
public Brooklyn Street with China when
the Chinese delivery guy yep caught
naked with my mom's high heels which now
flown off my shoes fell off like the
Jerky Boys wit my [ __ ] Miami Dolphins
henna and then they made me stay out
there for about two hours oh wow yeah
not selling and it was like a brisk
March day so so that happened so I was
like ah but these guys love me